an update to breaking news now a  homicide under investigation near  downtown las vegas let's get right out  to madison kimbrough live as police just  wrapped up a press conference madison  yeah this deadly altercation took place  around two this afternoon right off of  martin luther king boulevard that's  where they found a 29 year old man shot  currently metro is looking for the  suspect described as a black man with  dreadlocks you can still at sea it's a  very active scene whether the two knew  each other is unknown but we do know the  victim was shot in front of a house and  was found dead on scene so keep it here  on eight news now as we learn more  details and we will give you the latest  information reporting live madison  kimbrough live local now madison thank